[موسيقى]
يسعدني مقابلتك أوه ،
شكرًا لاستضافتي أخيرًا.
ولطيف لأن هذه
[الموسيقى
] لقد مرت 15 عامًا منذ ترسيمي ،
نعم ، كان الأمر صعبًا جدًا بالنسبة لي ،
لكني أود أن
أعرّفها على
أنها بداية فصل جديد من تومي أوه
نعم ، هذا رائع ، حسنًا ، نعم ،
نعم ،
في أي سن  هل بدأت عمري عندما كان
عمري 15 عامًا.
من
حشد كبير
على المسرح
أه نحتاج إلى
الحصول على بعض الطاقة لأداء ،
وقد منحني
الجمهور الطاقة اللطيفة جدًا ، لذلك كنت
سعيدًا جدًا على خشبة المسرح
[موسيقى] ،
فأنا أستلهم
الكثير من الأشياء
وأعتقد أن أكبر إلهام  الحصص الغذائية بالنسبة لي
هي نفسي ،
لذلك أضع
العديد من المشاعر المختلفة
في الموسيقى ، لذا
أعتقد أن هذا هو سبب حب الناس
لموسيقاي [ضحك]
أم
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
إنها فنانة رائعة
وآه ولديها  لديها
أسلوبها الخاص في الموسيقى
، وكذلك هل
هذا سيكون تعاونًا رائعًا ،
وأعتقد أنه سيكون من
المثير للاهتمام
إذا كان بإمكاني التعاون معها ، حسنًا ،
آمل أن ترى هذه المقابلة
ثم سنراكم معًا في هذه
الصورة.  أحبك
أوليفيا
[موسيقى]
لقد كان الأمر أسهل من ذي قبل
بسبب معجبي.
ممتن حقًا لذلك ،
شكرًا لك فيان
[موسيقى]
وفي الواقع أخبرني أصدقائي
أنها لذيذة
جدًا وأريد أن أجعلها في المنزل ،
يجب أن يكون الأمر سهلاً حقًا من حيث
المكونات والطريقة التي تفعلها  إنه سهل ولكن
المذاق ،
أنت تعلم ، نعم
نعم
تمسكني
[موسيقى]
أنت واثق جدًا من
الطعام الكوري الطعام الكوري
دجاج الكيمتشي ،
أوه ، هل أعجبك كل منهم
رائع ، أحب الطعام الكوري ، لقد أصنع
البعض منها
عندما أتيت إلى كوريا
[ضحك]
أربعة
أربعة خمسة أوه نعم هل سمعت  أنا
أعددت مكياجي اليوم
[موسيقى]
لذلك نشأت وأنا أستمع إليهم وما
زلت من أشد المعجبين بهم والتقيت
بهم شخصيًا لذلك كنت مثل حلم
أنهم لطيفون حقًا إنهم لطيفون جدًا
مهاراتك وتضع خططًا
للسفر ،
يا رهيب ،
حقًا ، حسنًا ،
كيف تشعر
من بين كل
سبع سبع لغات ، كم عدد اللغات التي تتحدث
الإنجليزية ،
هل تعرف
الإنجليزية الكورية قليلاً من
اليابانية ، أوه الصينية ،
نعم أنت ودود للغاية
جميل جدًا وأنت تعلم أن هذه هي
المرة الأولى التي ألتقي فيها وجهًا لوجه ، لكنك
قريب جدًا من القلب ،
أعتقد أنني شخص مرح وأعتقد
أن هذا لطيف يقول
أصدقائي دائمًا
أوه إنها
هي
هي  أطرف
أطرف شخص قابلته
[موسيقى]
شكراً جزيلاً
لكم  أنت كثيرًا على وقتك اليوم ،
حسنًا ،
حسنًا ، فقط
حرك رقبتك مثل رقبتي
يا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أنا
أجنبية